SPEAKER 1: Ever since man began
to fly, people came to watch.
The first passenger
flight in history
was not only seen by the
curious public, but by royalty.
Humanity's interest in flying
goes beyond the specific desire
to get into a cockpit
and take control
of a carefully
engineered machine,
streaking across the sky at
speeds not natural to man.
We also have a desire
to witness flight,
to simply be near flight.
To hear it, feel it,
and talk about it.
Because the incredible
feat of human powered
flight was conquered by a few,
but is appreciated by many.
This is the Farnborough
International Air Show,
one of the biggest air
shows in the world,
and a place that is as connected
to flying and aeronautics
as any other place on Earth.
Partly because it is the
site of the United Kingdom's
first human powered controlled
airplane flight back in 1908.
And over 100 years later, it is
still synonymous with flight.
But it's not just
the history that
keeps this place
flying high, it's
the continuous crowds
of interested people.
The people wanting to be
near flight, the people that
go to air shows.
RANDY TINSETH: It's a
celebration of flying.
And as I drove in today, I
saw people already lined up
with their cameras ready to
take pictures of these aircraft.
So I think there's a
pretty special thing,
a magic about flying.
You don't think about it.
Flying 35,000, 40,000
feet at 600 miles an hour,
connecting any two
places in the globe.
You know, flying has really
opened up what we can do,
what we can experience.
It's opened up business.
It really changed the world.
SPEAKER 1: And
it's that big idea,
that flight is this
magical, world changing
thing that makes people
want to be a witness to it.
To say they were there,
that they saw it up close,
they were one of the first to
see what could be possible.
JENNA MCMULLIN: The
excitement of flight
and the excitement
of space travel
is the excitement
of possibility.
It's the excitement of what if.
Where could we go, how
could we get there,
what if we tried this new idea?
SPEAKER 1: Talking to
people around the air show
and hearing their
conversations with each other,
the idea of the near
endless possibilities
aerospace can provide is
a big part of the draw.
Learning about what's
next in flight,
about space travel, drones
and flying airships.
But a lot of other people
break down the draw of an air
show more simply, like
Royal Air Force Squadron
Leader, Mark Faltz.
MARK: I just think airplanes
are generally quite cool.
SPEAKER 1: Now it may not
be the most poetic reason
why we're drawn to airplanes,
but it is definitely
a major factor.
Coolness is what makes kids
and adults look up with a grin
as an impressive aircraft
shows off for the crowd.
It's what makes people stare
upwards until their necks hurt.
It will literally stop
people in their tracks
as they watch something
they never thought possible.
Planes are a lot
of things, but cool
may be the first on the list.
But if you're
drawn to airplanes,
drawn to the power and
impressiveness of human flight,
it may not be any of this.
It may not be because you think
it's cool or inspirational.
It may be because of
something much, much deeper.
JEREMY VANDOMELEN: I think
it's a very primal instinct
that ever since the dawn
of man we looked at birds
and we've wondered how they fly.
And we're able to finally build
the machines to get up there.
And I think it's
just that feeling.
We dream of flying.
And I think that's
what drives it.
SPEAKER 1: Of course,
it's probably not
just one thing that makes people
interested in human flight.
Each person has a unique
take on what draws them in,
what makes them devote a
day, a weekend, or their life
to airplanes.
But the key to air
shows might come down
to a couple of simple things.
GUY NORRIS: Bit of history,
bit of the future, and right
outside the very present.
What more could you want?
SPEAKER 1: Over
the past few years,
there's been a worldwide
focus on STEM education.
And nowhere is
that more apparent
than in the schools'
Build A Plane Challenge
where school kids come
together to literally build
an airplane from scratch.
What was your favorite thing
about building the plane
in general?
STUDENT: That's really
hard, because I've enjoyed
building most of the plane.
I'm going to be a Naval
engineer when I'm older.
So this will help definitely.
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you for watching
and make sure to
subscribe for more videos.